- Can I learn a move?
I wanna learn a jiu-jitsu move.
- I'll totally, okay.
- Okay, let's do a jiu-jitsu move.
- Okay. Let's see.
- Okay, okay.
- We won't do any tosses.
We'll do a simple,
- Okay. Okay. Okay.
- We'll do like a simple
rear naked choke, alright?
- Okay.
- So-
- Did you say... a what?
- A rear naked choke.
Oh, it's got kind of a naughty name to it.
- Okay. Okay. Okay.
- So you'll go behind here, right?
- You're very close to me
while saying the word "naked".
- Yes. It's very intimate right here.
- I'm just saying.
- You'll go behind here.
You'll grab like, your...
- I think I've had this dream... okay.
- Put this, your hand behind this here,
(crowd laughing)
and then you start to squeeze
a little bit like that.
And then it'll start to hurt.
- (gasping) And it really works
- Yeah, when it starts
to hurt, you tap out.
- Okay. Tap.
- Okay? Yeah, you tap out.
- So wait, I'm not tall enough.
- Yeah, I'll go down here, I'll go down.
- Okay. Okay. Okay. So you squeeze...
- Are you right-handed?
- Yes.
- Okay go with your left hand.
- Oh, okay. Okay.
Interesting. So you do that.
I don't wanna hurt you.
- You're not gonna. No, I'll tap.
- Okay. Okay. Like that?
- Put your right hand behind.
- Right hand.
- Yeah. Put... no, grab this.
- Grab this?
- No, this hand grabs that bicep.
- Oh!
- Yeah. Now put this behind my head.
- [Producer] You can't hear his mic.
- Well, great. I can't hear (censored).
(audience laughs)
Okay.
- Okay. Okay. (laughing)
(crowd cheering)
- I can't even reach. I, oh my God.
Do you know what?
You know what? I literally...
- No, but that was effective.
Like, you can, next time a
guy's outta line with you,
you can put 'em to sleep.
- I have abnormally, I'll just
aim for the (censored) man.
(both laughing)
- Then you'll get down and then you got...
- I have abnormally... you just
found something to about me.
I have abnormally short arms.
They are, they're like abnormally short.
So I was like, I can't even
reach my other, it's fine.
I was like, I love, every
time I have you on here
we're always doing some kind of activity.
Last time we, it was with
your daughter, right?
We were doing the dancing?
- That's right. We were dancing. Yeah.
- Every time we have to do an activity.